all right
ps4 pro Pete you're like our one of our
resident tech experts for experts Wow
Tec Tec H spurt like you're spurting
tech yes I was at the PlayStation event
in New York last week it was relatively
light compared to I thought I mean I'm
surprised they showed both I mean we
definitely expected to slim because we
knew like there for those leaks that
Sony you know still didn't confirm it
after those leaks a few weeks ago but
yeah they showed off the pro as well
with like HDR compatibility obviously
they could 4k if you have a 4k TV it's
the club sandwich of video game consoles
yeah exactly
three layers that's what I was gonna say
yeah pew sport pro it's interesting
times we are in you know we've seen a
lot of consoles kind of get these like
hardware revisions some with like the
most modest upgrades that maybe a
developer would notice but you wouldn't
pro is sort of and you can maybe point
to xbox one ass but
ps4 Pro is really the first step in in
terms of you know these like semi
console generation start going exist
anymore it seems like he's just like you
know midterm updates to a system and
it's coming with things like HDR and 4k
and there's a lot of stipulations there
in terms of how those things will apply
I mean the nice thing is that the HDR
feature will apply to all PlayStation
fours unlike Xbox one which is currently
only doing it on the S but 4k is pretty
much the focus of the pro we can also
assume VR will be a focus and it's gonna
be interesting I think for developers as
well as the audience to deal with this
division of the market you were just
telling me the other day we're talking
my battlefield one having you know they
had that bundle and on some Monday that
was like you know HDR support wherever I
was like digging deeper because I don't
know too much about the PS pro but that
also depends on the developer releasing
the HDR 4k for for PlayStation Pro
specifically right they have to allow
that to happen yeah yeah so 4k is not a
guarantee it sounds like now we're going
to see some games that are native 4k
they're gonna be very modest games in
terms of technical demands other games
will render
lower-resolution be scaled up to output
at 4k so it'll still fill your 4k TV at
that resolution but it's not rendered
natively their HDR seems to be a thing
like 4k that is going to be optional for
developers and if they if they want to
have it work they have to enable it in
terms of like sure you might get HDR on
the PlayStation 4 Pro even though
standard ps4 supports HDR I don't think
that means you're automatically going to
get it for any game that supports it on
PlayStation Pro this confusion is just
is already confusing as hell and you're
wondering if it's this is just becoming
the reality of obviously like console
generations now reacting like how long
did it take like PC audiences they've
always been used to this stuff like
upgrading tech but it's still it's weird
because I think being consoles people
assume it's just gonna be this set
evolution that takes place yes and you
know I think with PC like you said
people are used to the idea that the
quality of a game is going to be in flux
relative to their hardware console
gamers have always just expected a
certain standard and I think a lot of
that will persist but it's going to
become difficult when people are just
choosing what console to buy it's not
going to be does does is my console
strong enough for this game right like
once they have a ps4 Pro or slim I think
people gonna understand like ok I can
really only focus on games that have
this tech but making that choice that's
gonna be hard for a lot of people yeah
but luckily for Sony once people make
that decision they're pretty much in
good shape and I think you're gonna see
a lot of people picking up the pro as
opposed to the slim sure what do you
think the price points now you're
speaking about slimming Pro so the slim
starts at 3 read write and then pros 4
right so we don't know how much Scorpio
is going to cost it sounds like
Microsoft is you know based on their
their presentation to e3 like really
doubling down on this thing and trying
to hit a homerun that might be a more
expensive system but one of the things
driving down the cost of the Pro is that
it doesn't have a UHD blu-ray drive in
it which means you cannot watch 4k
content off of a disc you have to stream
it that is something that is built into
the Xbox 1s yeah so a weird omission for
the protein
it's a weird ok why that might have in
the case um I think it's a it's an easy
move for Sony to keep costs down
because let's be honest I think 4k for a
lot of people it's gonna be hard to
discern that difference unless something
like you know you walk into a store and
you see is like really intricate nature
documentaries on 4k like yeah a flower
under a macro lens is gonna look amazing
sure but but like a Hollywood
blockbuster like you're gonna you know
in the explosion of the fire you're
gonna miss all that stuff as it's moving
by really fast so I think cutting costs
they're allowing people to stream 4k
from services they already subscribe to
is not going to necessarily hamper their
4k entertainment experience they'll have
access to it from Microsoft I think it's
a boon for the Xbox one ass that helps
them sell that system a little bit
better it is the cheapest UHD player out
there on the other hand it is strange
it's not on the pro because Sony
basically owns the blu-ray format it is
something that they pioneered and that
they have been a champion of for so long
so it's a little strange and that starts
at $400 am i correct yeah the pro I
think that has an excellent price it's
going to it's going to be really telling
how it'll impact PlayStation VR and how
many games can really support 4k for
people to understand that argument and
really go for it and if you don't have a
4k TV you don't even make a thousand
dollars you're probably gonna drive
people people like to future-proof how
many of us bought Xbox 360s before we
had an HDTV right you know definitely
and that's the thing with me it was
definitely it was I definitely did buy
one before I had refurbished 360 I still
have my launch day 360 than ever yeah it
got a red ring but I wrapped the towel
around and I still have it I'm not
kidding still Mattel yeah it's done I
haven't checked it works but it's still
in my room in a towel no but um I got to
see a few games up close because HDR
obviously like you were saying it's
definitely more noticeable than 4k to me
yes right yeah I think yeah and HDR is
the exciting thing for me cuz like
obviously if you have like any kind of
like interest in photography HDR is a
big deal I can phone iPhone have it now
as of the six I believe but the thing
with it was kind of weird because at the
presentation people around me were all
saying they showed a few games during
the presentation with the old graphics
as opposed to right the HDR and then we
went backstage and Naughty Dog had both
the last little mastered
and uncharted 4 obviously Last of Us
remastered at its foundation as a ps3
game still looked really good with them
the ps4 pro but then they had a button
that they had equipped like I think
they're present a touchpad for the
purposes of this presentation and
they're switching between the like
Nathan Drake was swimming underwater in
a coral reef at one point later and like
in a liberté Lia and uncharted 4 but the
original footage looked worse because
like I just played this game in March or
ever was I don't member looking that bad
and like I thought I was just being
crazy but and I don't wanna I'm not like
accusing Sony or Naughty Dog or anything
but do it other people were saying is
that just looking this bad in comparison
to the ps4 pro with HDR HDR definitely
looked really good but the original
footage looked like I had an extra layer
of fog over it it depends on a lot on
the TV you're playing and the settings
that are applied to it maybe those TVs
weren't calibrated appropriately yeah I
don't know it just looks that much
tensional II yep or yeah you wonder like
if there's any doctoring to make the old
footages look words in comparison
but here's the thing I don't think they
would do that because HDR is going to
work for existing PlayStation 4 runners
so it doesn't influence their decision
to buy a ps4 Pro so there's actually a
Center for Sony to do that right if
you've got a ps4 already it's gonna work
anything a lot of people those events
definitely have one probably are you
guys tempted to buy the pro now assuming
obviously the slim is good for people
who don't have a ps4 there's no reason
to buy a ps4 slim purportedly if you
have it before already I want to know I
want to know more about the
manufacturing process that goes into
this because my ps4 I like the way it
looks it's a little loud mm-hmm I want a
quieter system the ps4 pro can give me
more power and be quire than the santur
ps4 yeah probably a couple years I'll
buy one yeah if if they're gonna adopt
this like Apple ask s release why can't
we have that whole system right like why
can't I exchange my ps4 well you can't
even take it to Game Stop and get 20
bucks for it it's just like that's
what's the killer for me you know I'm
sure for everyone's like like my buddy a
buddy mine just got a ps4 great it's
just I think I'll eventually get one I
mean that's you know this is like our
job here you you want to have the best
equipment for the job but I don't know
it's such a kill four hundred bucks is a
lot yeah I mean it was actually I think
it's a fair price point compared to I
thought it would be but at this point
you have 400
doesn't seem like something I want to
drop on this but then another thing that
the presentation about the presentation
that stood out that we had been talking
about they never once during the
presentation said this is the most
powerful console like remember like Xbox
one for the Scorpio presentation they
were like this is gonna be the most
powerful console ever made at this point
right and like you were just touching on
this how like this in a lot of ways can
become a boon for the Scorpio and that's
because of its blue right capabilities
but I know it's almost like Sony's
pushing though this is the most powerful
console for the time being
in November whatever launches with
PlayStation VR and everything yeah but
you think they would have pushed that if
that were true but I mean obviously like
the Scorpio is still the one that I'm
more curious about
I think Sony is doing their best to
court existing PlayStation owners to buy
it the new version I think their market
share kind of speaks for itself in
relational Microsoft where Microsoft
really has to account for the fact that
they've had the weaker of the two main
consoles since launch and that has been
the narrative around it so maybe it's
true that Sony's PlayStation 4 Pro will
not be as powerful as Scorpio who knows
if they know that or not but they also
don't need to really try to back up that
claim and if they were to make that
claim now before Scorpio is announced
and we really know what's in it and
proved wrong that would suck sure so I
think I can understand why they wouldn't
do that yeah you know it's like we try
to like avoid absolutes like absolute
statements in previews and stuff like
that but for good reason right because
things change and we don't always know
everything and I think that's the place
where Sony is right now it's interesting
to look at you wonder how much of this
is just a reaction to Microsoft the
Scorpio obviously like the rumors the
Neo came out like giant bomb had been
reporting on the actual like information
about it you wonder if they push this up
farther because of the Scorpio and like
obviously like NX news is rumored to be
coming out really soon now and that's
gonna be what like quarter to next year
March purportedly okay you wonder how
much this is like reactionary as opposed
to something Sony had planned all along
I don't know how fast they can pivot in
that respect when it comes to the actual
economics behind the scenes and like you
said manufacturing which I don't have
much background in but I don't know I'm
wondering if this was something they
pushed forward a little bit well the
good thing about for Sony and Microsoft
is they're working with AMD to make
parts that are relatively simple for
manufacturers
those chips to adapt to in the past you
know the PlayStation 3 was notorious for
being the most inefficient console to
create the chips that powered it for
various reasons I think this has more to
do potentially with the launch of
PlayStation VR more than anything and
that's that's sort of spurred Sony's
expediency in this regard to get out
there first I think they were just ready
to frankly and you know it's it's also
worth noting that maybe Microsoft is
biding their time so they can wait and
see what other people do before they
actually commit to what Scorpio is it
might be the inverse it might not be
Sony being reactionary might be
Microsoft just being slow or you know
patient well sure yeah anyway the slim
is definitely obviously like I said for
like people who might not be in the game
yet as far as this console generation
goes but the pro is the one they're like
we're looking for especially with like
considered pro coming out plus buying
psvr which is how much $400 so four
hundred plus four hundred plus if you
haven't upgraded to a 4k TV yet that
could be like 1,800 bucks if you want to
completely upgrade all at once use it
that much I thought 4k TVs were fairly I
was thinking around I was like oh yeah
$500 well you want to get one that's a
decent size because you're not gonna
notice the difference in resolution if
you have something that's like 32 inches
I don't even know if you can buy it I'm
sure you can but you really want to be
like 50 inches in above yeah and so
beyond that there are a lot of different
things that come like with HDR like II
need a TV that has 4k and the proper HDR
support I've seen people who have been
picking up Xbox 1s is thinking their TVs
up to snuff they plug it in and the
console is like yeah you're missing this
stuff you can get a little bit of a
benefit so it's like if you want to get
the TV that has everything you need
you're not gonna find that cheap
knockoff made in China
not knockoff you're gonna be buying you
know that well I'm not I get economic 4k
TV you're gonna be buying one that's a
little bit more robust or like the first
generations of for Kane right like they
have improved over the years it was like
a leftovers I guess right sure
so what's the price range for like a 4k
TV I was thinking like oh tonight like a
decent one was like a thousand I could
be over shooting that I was looking the
other day during this announcement just
loosely not really like based on these
hard specs I was just referring to and I
kept seeing 60 inches between 800 and
$1,000 okay
from
like Samsung like manufacturers it's
like okay I will probably look to you
you can get a 4k TV cheap but will it
support everything else I don't know is
it worth it at that point sure so yeah
yeah this the ps4 slim is releasing
September 15th 2016 and that's gonna be
three hundred dollars whereas ps4 Pro is
November 10th 2016 for $400 so let us
know what you think do you have a ps4
already and you're playing getting a
slim probably not are you planning on
getting a pro November 10th let us know
in the comments below